Ouch!
Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Nice!
Das funktioniert, nice.
So, Filters gucken.
Passt alles, alles gut.
Gut, ähm...
Dann warte ich mal, bis das Stream richtig online ist.
Heute basteln wir wieder ein bisschen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir was Gescheites gekauft habe oder nicht.
Müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Man gönnt sich ja sonst nix.
Moin!
Da ist da Toxic auch am Start.
Komm, wir haben heute Kamera-Action.
Oh, warum ruckelt das?
Was ist hier los?
Es sind aber keine 60 FPS von meiner Hand.
Neues Nass daheim.
Nicht wirklich nur neues Nass.
Ich bin gerade damit überlegen, ob ich meine Intel...
Low-Power-Intel-Kiste dadurch ersetze.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Mal gucken, ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir nur gekauft, weil es mir danach war.
Einfach weil ich mir gedacht habe, ey, wir brauchen was Neues.
Hier guckt, also das ist ein...
Zeig es euch mal, wobei man kann das hochkant, kann man das, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Gar nicht richtig stellen.
Guckt mal hier, das ist ein...
Wenn man das jetzt sieht...
Ein HP Microserver Gen 10 Plus.
Ist aber auch schon zwei Jahre alt.
Das Teil.
Also, weil es rausgekommen ist.
Das ist nicht das neueste.
Und so ultra-low-power wie mein aktueller Intel-low-power...
Ist es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber was ich an der Sache ganz nice finde, ist, dass es halt einfach komplett...
Fertiges Teil ist.
Eigentlich falsch investiert.
Warum?
Riecht danach, dass der gut Stromhunger hat.
Ich weiß es nicht. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Also, wir können uns das angucken.
Ich habe ja hier den Watt-Champ dran.
Können wir gleich mal gucken, was es braucht.
Aus der Firma gesnackt.
Nein, nein, habe ich mir bestellt bei Amazon.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich habe heute meine dritte 5G-Antenne bekommen.
Heute Morgen.
Beim Samstag beim Doktor.
Ich habe auch gedacht, was ist mit euch los?
Warum vergebt ihr Samstags Termine?
Aber ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Ja.
Dritte 5G-Antenne am Start.
Der CuteBot hat wieder Bettge gemacht.
Ja, der Bot im Discord ist teilweise echt lahm.
Ah, ja, ja.
Richtig.
Massive.
Ah, ja, ja.
Wir gucken uns das heute mal zusammen an.
Ich werde das nicht fertig einrichten.
Also, was wir uns mal angucken.
Ich mache hier oben erst einmal Fullscreen.
Dann klein.
Wir machen das mal auf.
Gucken mal rein.
Hier ist...
Busy?
Busy weiter drehen, können wir das noch?
Wobei...
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Hier ist...
Hier ist Tischgrenze. Nee, passt.
Seitdem ist der WLAN-Empfang schlechter.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ja, Kiyokun 27 Monate.
Richtig nice hier.
Dafür bräuchte man eigentlich eine neue Keksfarbe.
Aber habe ich nicht.
Gleich fällt die Cam um.
Die Cam kann nicht umfallen.
Die Kamera ist zwischen diesem Elgato Ringlight montiert.
Und das ist sehr massiv an einem recht massiven Tisch fest.
Ich meine, der Tisch wackelt.
Und noch nicht mal großartig, wenn man draufhaut.
Was ist besser? Minis Forum Elite HM 80.
Warum ist das besser?
Es hat keinen PCIe Express-Slot.
Für 10G.
Und es hat keinen Wechselrahmen für Platten.
Was soll man damit? Bringt mir doch überhaupt nichts.
Hat keinen Wechselrahmen für Platten.
Hat keinen PCIe Express-Slot.
Was soll man damit?
Ist das der HP mit dem Xeon?
Ja, die gibt es in zwei Varianten.
Warte mal, wo steht das denn jetzt?
Ja, also die gibt es in zwei Varianten.
Den gibt es mit einem Xeon E2224 und einem Pentium G.
Also Silber.
Noch was, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe die Variante mit dem Xeon.
Man kann da sogar einen ILO reinpappen mittlerweile.
Und Remote drauf zugreifen.
Aber ich habe es ohne ILO-Kit gekauft.
Heute mir tut der Arm ein bisschen weh.
Da wächst die neue Antenne gerade.
Heute Morgen gab es wieder richtig Drama beim Doktor.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit manchen Leuten los ist.
Ich saß im Wartezimmer.
Was ist die Geschichte mit der...
Ach ja, warte mal. Lass mal überlegen, da war was.
Was war denn das nochmal?
Chat erinnert mich mal dran.
Ach so, ja, genau.
Wir haben gemietet.
Gut, dass du fragst.
Es ist genau so gewesen, wie ich es im Stream vermutet habe.
Das ist nur vorgeschoben gewesen.
Ich soll ihm zeigen, wie man eine Datei löscht.
Es sind dann noch zwei Leute
von diesem Dienstleister aufgetaucht,
der für uns die Software für diesen Server entwickelt.
Und eigentlich wollten die nur,
dass ich ihnen eine File Liste erzeuge
mit Dateien, die sie später löschen können.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die das immer so verschleiern müssen.
Und nicht einfach sagen können, was Sache ist.
Dann haben wir auf der Arbeit übrigens
zweiten Corona-Fall.
Jetzt sind alle zwangs Homeoffice.
Ich bin ja eh schon
dauer Homeoffice gerade.
Also Leute, ich zeige euch
jetzt mal kurz die Hardware,
was wir hier am Start haben,
bevor wir anfangen.
Ich habe einmal mir diesen
Mikroserver gekauft.
Wisst ihr, was gut ist?
Ich bin jetzt gezwungen, die Maus raus
zu bewegen, dass hier oben das X weggeht.
Das ist gut, weil ansonsten vergesse ich immer
die Maus im Bild.
Also, was haben wir da am Start?
Ich glaube, ich muss gleich nochmal einen Bonbon futtern.
Also, was haben wir am Start?
Wir haben einmal am Start
kriege ich irgendwie eine gescheite Vorschau.
Wo habe ich denn mein Tablet?
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz meinen Stream aufmachen.
Auf dem Tablet.
Damit ich gescheite Chat
Vorschau habe.
Wenn ich in die andere Richtung
gucke. Sonst funktioniert das ja nicht.
Also,
wo
will ich öffnen auf Twitch?
Yes, I consent.
Google Cookies, alles klar.
Da sind wir doch, nice.
Da sind wir doch.
So, wir haben ein Breitbild. Wir accepten
auch da Cookies.
Jetzt muss ich mir erstmal Lost Ark Werbung
angucken. Leute, mal
wenn ihr euch die Lost Ark gespielt haben.
Lohnt sich das jetzt noch, sich das zu geben?
Ich meine, das Game ist ja irgendwie seit 6 Jahren
in Korea oder sind es 8 Jahre, irgendwie 2014
in Korea raus.
Was ja irgendwie lächerlich ist, dass es so lange
gedauert hat, bis es überhaupt
hier am Start ist.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob das ein Game mit Endgame
ist.
Oder ob das halt so ein Game ist, was du
spielst und dann ist gut. Ich weiß, dass es
ein MMO ist, aber das heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass es ein Game
mit Endgame ist, was einen länger als 2 Monate
maximal bei der Stange hält.
Hm.
Irgendwie
mag
mein iPad meinen Stream nicht
öffnen.
Anzeige ist
raus, warum nicht?
Jetzt kommt bestimmt gleich der Chat so nach dem Motto
zu viele Pornhop Tabs auf oder
irgendwie sowas. Ich habe keine
Ahnung, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal
den Stream aufmachen, sonst kann ich nicht gescheit
Vorschau gucken, weil ich gucke ja hier
in eine andere Richtung, wie da mein Monitor
ist. Altewiger Kreiselgrind,
das muss sein. Nice, jetzt kriege ich nochmal
Lost Ark Werbung. Pock, sehr schön.
Da habe ich drauf gewarnt. Guck uns 2 Mal
Lost Ark Werbung an, alles klar.
Das ist
muss man dem Chat nicht 2
Mal sagen. So, jetzt habe ich hier
das iPad stehen.
Habe ich hier nämlich noch was, wo ich gucken kann,
was der Chat so schreibt. Da steht das
iPad, da ist mein
also, da steht das iPad,
da ist mein Monitor.
So in die Richtung,
da so, da.
Deswegen, ich gucke in die andere
Richtung, sonst sehe ich euch nicht.
Einen guten
Anbieter, bei dem man eine öffentliche
IPv4 mieten kann, um dich
als VPN zu benutzen.
Du kannst dir...tja
Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen.
VPN
Ich muss euch was erzählen.
Nord
VPN hat bei mir angefragt,
ob ich nicht Werbung für sie
machen möchte.
Und da habe ich, ja,
mein...
Ich werde jetzt nichts erzählen,
was nicht stimmt.
Aber es hat ja durchaus positive
Aspekte, über die man reden kann.
Zum Beispiel das, was ich Netflix gucke,
von Serien, die es hier
noch nicht gibt und solche Dinge. Also das würde ich
schon, würde ich schon
prinzipiell machen, wenn halt so die Rahmenbedingungen
stimmen. Und dann meinten die so, ah ja, nice, nice, nice,
machen wir. Und gestern,
gestern, gestern
antwortete dann einer dort noch per
Mail so nach dem Motto, ah,
Max, mir ist da noch
was Problematisches aufgefallen
auf deinem Channel.
Und da hat er dieses Video hier gefunden.
Ja, und
da hat er das Video hier gefunden
und irgendwie wollen sie jetzt
nicht mehr mit Nord VPN.
Das kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
Ich habe jetzt doch angeboten,
na ja, ich habe ja in dem Video auch
thematisiert,
dass es durchaus
sinnvolle Punkte gibt.
Und ich habe, ich würde ja
eh nichts erzählen, wovon ich nicht
der Meinung bin, dass es was bringt. Also
ich kann das gerne thematisieren,
mal gucken, mal gucken, ob die wollen. Aber was
ich witzig finde, dass die
erst einschreiben, dann mit einem was
aushandeln und dann danach auf den Channel
gucken, obwohl die dich
immer anschreiben mit so nach dem Motto,
Max, dein Content ist super, wir gucken
dich schon 300 Jahre. Das schreiben die immer.
Das ist Schwachsinn. Ich meine, das weiß jeder, dass es nicht so ist.
Aber das schreiben die alle immer.
Und dann fällt sie ihn da noch auf.
Hast du eigentlich Patreon oder so?
Ne. Du kannst entweder
Twitch subscriben oder YouTube
subscriben, das geht ja mittlerweile auch.
YouTube kannst du sogar für 2.99
subscriben, für Kixi-Modes, die kannst du
mal auf YouTube verwenden.
Jo.
Ansonsten kannst du einfach
zugucken und nichts machen.
Was hier ist eine Frage, die niemand
bisher gestellt hat. Das Video ist ja schon etwas älter.
Geht da nicht das Fragezeichen?
Naja, VPN,
hab ich doch gesagt, du kannst dir
einen x-beliebigen VPN-Anbieter
raussuchen, wenn du eine öffentliche IPv4
Adresse haben willst.
Wie das mit Portweiteleitung ist, muss man
bei denen auf der Seite gucken, aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass es auch kein Ding ist.
Zumal du ja in der
Regel ein 1 zu 1 Mapping hast, also
da musst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel
weiterleiten, sondern du irgendwas freigeben.
Also ich denke mal, das
wird auf jeder
Anbieterseite stehen.
Ansonsten, wenn der Chat irgendwas weiß
für Michael 50 Billion, was
ein super Anbieter ist
mit einer öffentlichen IPv4 Adresse, ich meine, klar,
du kannst dir auch bei Hetzen einen Server mieten und dich
irgendwie tunneln.
Kommt halt immer auf den jeweiligen technischen Skill
und Stand an.
Genau. Am besten subs du auf
YouTube, auf Twitch und boostest den Discord-Server.
So ist das. Exzellent.
Exzellent. So muss man das machen.
Sieh ich auch so.
Ja, aber mit
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner kriegst du ein 20 Euro
Startgutschein von mir.
Und dann ist das ganze schon wieder viel besser.
Ach ne, kriegst du ja nicht.
Das ist ja ausgelaufen
letztes Jahr.
Nur bis 31.12.
Sekunde, ich guck mal, was die geschrieben haben
für dieses Jahr. Ich hab letztens gesagt
und wie sie jetzt mal gesagt
hier, lief ja eigentlich ganz gut letztes Jahr.
Wollen wir nicht dieses Jahr auch mal uns
irgendwas überlegen. Natürlich in der Hoffnung, dass wir
neue Konditionen aushandeln können.
Jetzt, wo ich einen Manager hab, der sich um solche Sachen kümmert,
ist das gut. Da muss ich mich nämlich nicht selbst drum kümmern.
Aber
ne, die haben Urlaub bei Hetzner.
Solange sich da keiner meldet bei Hetzner,
gibt es kein Hetzner Link. Da kann man nichts machen.
Und auch keine Werbung.
Ich hab wieder komische Anfragen gekriegt
von Dingern,
von denen ich im Leben nichts gehört hab.
Keine Ahnung. Na gut.
So, ich mach den Chat mal wieder auf, dass ich euch sehe.
Also, Max hat einen Manager.
Ja, hab ich. Hab ich aber schon vor einer Weile erzählt,
dass ich jemand hab, der sich ein bisschen um so
die Business-Donk-Sachen kümmert
mittlerweile.
Was er übrigens auch richtig gut macht,
er ist halt super eingespannt, er kann sich bei mir jetzt nicht
Vollzeit drum kümmern. Ja, also
wen's interessiert.
Wenn ihr Business-Anfragen habt,
könnt ihr euch auch direkt an ihn wetten.
Aber am besten ist weiter. Ihr schreibt dann eine Business-E-Mail-Adresse.
Ja.
Das ist mein Manager.
Die Manager-Diff
schlägt zu.
Sagen wir mal hier mal ein bisschen größer.
Reicht so ein Tunnel nicht Google Cloud Free?
Ja, kannst du auch machen.
Oracle Free Tier.
Das Oracle Free Tier wollten wir tatsächlich schon mal
seit über einem Jahr oder so ausprobieren.
Woher kennst du den? Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig,
die Geschichte. Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ich
lerne nicht freiwillig neue Leute kennen.
Wie ich heute Morgen auf Twitter
geschrieben habe.
Sobald ich mich länger als 10 Minuten
mit echten Leuten auseinandersetzen muss,
bin ich abgefuckt. Hoch 10.
Raste ich komplett aus.
Und das war ganz witzig.
Ich hab doch mal
Modern Warfare 2019
Beta Keys bei mir
verlost auf Twitter. 10 Stück
waren das, glaube ich. Und der hat damals
einen gewonnen.
Und darauf hin haben wir,
ich meine, ich hab mir das Profil der Leute
immer ein bisschen angeguckt,
mit denen ich die Keys geschickt habe.
Und daraufhin
haben wir ein halbes Jahr später oder so.
Deswegen hatte ich die noch in den PNs drinne.
Und irgendwann haben wir
ein halbes Jahr später oder so, hat da
eine PN geschrieben, ob wir nicht ein bisschen
MW1, also 2019 spielen wollen.
Nee, nicht
ein halbes Jahr später. Ziemlich direkt
zu Release, glaube ich, war das schon.
Und da waren auch
irgendwelche Valorant Pros dabei
und so was. Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, was
machst du denn sonst so? Dann meinte, ja, ich manage
gerade ein Valorant-Team,
bin auch so in dem Bereich aktiv. Und irgendwie
haben wir uns eigentlich ganz gut verstanden und haben uns
dann darauf geeinigt, es wäre doch nicht schlecht,
wenn er sich ein bisschen um die Business-Stonks-Sachen
bei mir kümmert. Das funktioniert
eigentlich ganz gut.
Ist bei mir auch so,
muss man aber für die IT nicht mit vielen
anderen Leuten kommunizieren. Nee, gerade
deswegen geht man doch an die IT, dass man mehr mit
Technik zu tun hat, weniger mit echten Personen.
Echte Personen
gehen mir mega auf den Sack.
Leute, ich sag euch, letzte Woche,
ich hab mehr gemietet, als ich sinnvolle Sachen gemacht
hab. Unglaublich. Ich glaube, ich hab drei
oder vier Tage bin ich ja insgesamt da.
Ich arbeite ja nur vier Tage in die Woche.
Ich hab ohne Scheiß
in diesen vier Tagen nichts gearbeitet.
Außer geschwätzt.
Und ne, doch nebenbei hab ich ein paar Sachen gemacht.
Das konntest du komplett vergessen.
Und kennt ihr diese Leute?
Super high IQ Meeting, Leute.
Es ist
irgendeine Besprechung. Es sind irgendwie
fünf, sechs Leute eingeladen.
Und ihr fragt euch
schon die ganze Zeit, was mach ich hier
eigentlich? Dann kommt
mal irgendein Punkt, wozu ihr was
sagen könnt. Da sagt ihr, ja, wir
haben jetzt auch hier mal abgecradet
und nach dem Upgrade ist das System
20% schneller und
eigentlich ganz okay, was die da
gebastelt haben. So, nächster. Und dann
hast du Leute, die
werden richtig hibbelig, wenn sie seit 15
Minuten nichts gesagt haben. Und wenn die seit 15
Minuten nichts gesagt haben, dann stellen sie so
Schein-Zwischenfragen. Kennt ihr die Leute, die so
Schein-Rückfragen stellen in Meetings?
So nach dem Motto, du sagst, ja,
wir haben jetzt geupgradet, das System ist jetzt 20%
schneller. Und dann kommen dann so
Rückfragen wie so, aha,
ihr habt das System
Upgraded. Bedeutet das auch,
das System ist jetzt schneller?
Ha, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, und was sagt der Hersteller?
Aha, ja, ja.
Einfach nur so
Schein-Rückfragen stellen, um mal was
zu sagen, um wichtig zu erscheinen, dass man
eben seine Anwesenheit
rechtfertigt. Kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Oder kennt ihr die Leute,
die
immer exakt so lange mieten, wie das
Meeting eingetragen ist? So irgendein Typ
lädt eine Stunde ein zum Meeting,
du bist nach 20 Minuten fertig
und die restlichen 40 Minuten, anstatt
zu sagen, ja gut, einmal alles
besprochen, machen wir mal was Sinnvolles,
wird dann nochmal das gleiche durchgekaut
oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen durchgekaut
oder er hält irgendein Monolog über eine halbe Stunde
über irgendwelche Dinge, die er sonst
noch so macht. Das geht dann,
wenn der eine Stunde eingetragen hat,
dann geht das auch eine Stunde.
Leute,
ich muss heute ein bisschen was trinken
zwischendurch.
So,
aber,
jetzt sind ja alle da im Chat,
sehe ich auch.
Ja,
das sind die meisten Meetings. Die meisten
Meetings könnten der Teams Message sein.
Und dann gibt es noch die Leute,
die wegen jedem Scheiß anrufen, anstatt
eine Message zu schreiben. Kennt ihr die
auch? Anstatt zu schreiben,
ah Max, ich hab ausprobiert, es funktioniert,
callt er dich dann irgendwann
15.40 Uhr
und sagt, ah Max, ich hab's ausprobiert, es funktioniert.
Die können
nicht einfach eine Teams Message schreiben.
Ja, gibt's genug, ne?
Ich glaub schon, ich glaub,
Oracle Free Tier ist eine VM.
Die billigste VM, die sie haben, aber ich meine
Free Tier.
Er macht dir nichts raus,
so typisch Andy.
Mit den meisten
Buzzwords können auch die Leute, die mit sich
um sich werfen, damit nichts anfangen.
Lasst ihr mal von einem
schlüssig erklären, was Cloud Native
ist.
Da geht's los.
Ja,
das stimmt.
Ein Buzzword.
So, aber, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen
Thema heute. Ich mach mal hier Fullscreen.
Also, passt mal auf, Leute.
Crashless war auch gut. Was war Crashless?
Das hatten wir letztens im Stream. Genau,
Crashless Update haben wir das letzte Mal
gemacht.
Ja, Patrick,
so ungefähr würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch
umschreiben. Also, eine Applikation,
die entwickelt wurde, explizit um in der Cloud
zu laufen, eben mit Technologien, die dort
besonders gut zur Geltung kommen. Und nichts,
was man so quasi
noch von Alt auf Cloud umzieht, so
irgendwie in der Richtung, wenn ich, ja, wahrscheinlich
würde ich das auch so beschreiben.
Kamera,
das ist ein
Definitionssache.
Kann man, ja, ist immer
Definitionssache. Und wisst ihr, was ich auch
geil finde, was bei uns super auf der Arbeit
immer ist? Kennt ihr Projekte,
die scheitern? Also, bei uns gibt es keine
Projekte, die scheitern oder Projekte,
die kein gutes Ergebnis
haben. Bei uns sind alle Projekte
immer super zufriedenstellend, werden die abgeschlossen.
Also, bei uns gibt es keine Projekte,
die fehlschlagen.
Was wir machen ist, wir
definieren kurz vor Projektende
aus den 100%, 20%
raus und sagen, das sind die
neuen 100%.
Also, man macht
quasi nur einen Fünftel
und sagt dann am Ende, das Fünftel
ist aber eigentlich jetzt 100%.
Und dann sind die Projekte immer super erfolgreich
fertig. Das Fivehead,
learnings, ja, learnings
hat man daraus immer ganz viel mitgenommen.
Bei uns sagt man
aber nicht learnings, bei uns sagt man, das ist
auch so eine Redewendung bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Wir kennen jetzt die Schwächen,
sagen sie bei uns immer. Wir kennen
jetzt die Schwächen.
Das ist auch so ein absolutes Füllwort, das kannst
du bei uns theoretisch überall einwerfen
und alle sagen so, ah, okay,
wir kennen jetzt die Schwächen, okay, okay, next,
nächstes Thema, please.
Die Schwächen, das ist doch
egal von was, wir kennen jetzt die Schwächen.
Du darfst bei solchen Sachen nicht erwarten,
dass es irgendwie Sinn ergibt.
Das ist genau das Gleiche,
wie auf irgendwelchen Meetings immer
gemacht wird, ja, da sind wir dran
oder, ah, das nehme ich mit.
Das ist auch so ein Ding. Da geht es nicht
darum, um was Sinnvolles zu sagen, da geht es darum,
dass die Leute sagen, okay, ich hake das
jetzt in meinem Protokoll ab,
Wiedervorlage nächste Woche
und tschüss. Da geht es nicht darum, dass da
wirklich was passiert, als würdest du da
irgendwas mitnehmen oder als würdest du an irgendwas dran sein.
So, jetzt aber, jetzt kommen wir
mal zur eigentlichen Geschichte heute.
Setze jetzt Android
bei dir zu Hause ein, ne, noch nicht, noch habe ich
meine hier hinten im Serverraum,
das steht so da, so steht das dann.
Ähm, übrigens, die Katze hat heute zugeschlagen,
guck mal.
Zählt das, zählt das schon, zählt das schon
auf Twitch unter Selbstverletzung, ich wäre jetzt
gebannt, ich habe mich ja nicht selbst verletzt, die Katze
hat mich verletzt.
Ja, also aktuell habe ich da hinten im Serverraum,
da, da so, habe ich noch
ein, ähm, Low Power Intel
Kiste stehen, aber ich probiere Android auf der Kiste
jetzt mal ein bisschen aus. Also,
Handlig, ja,
wir gucken uns das mal zusammen an,
was wir so hier am Start haben.
Also, hier haben wir einmal
einen
Ich hoffe, man sieht das jetzt gescheit.
Einen HP Microserver
Generation 10 Plus.
Das Ding ist aber auch schon zwei Jahre
alt, wo es rausgekommen ist, ist nicht mal das
Allerneueste. Aber ich habe gehört, man gönnt sich
ja sonst nichts. Wir gucken da auch
gleich rein, weil wir müssen ein bisschen was umbauen.
Oder was einbauen oder so.
Standardmäßig hat der,
ich glaube, hier vorne,
bin ich mir nicht sicher, müssen wir gucken, ich glaube, hier vorne
vier Einschübe für Festplatten
und hinten
Sekunde, mal gucken,
ob man das jetzt sieht.
Und hinten hast du
einen PCI Express
PCI Express Low Profile
Steckplatz, einen ILO
Steckplatz
und eine
Ich weiß nicht, ob die austauschbar ist, ehrlich gesagt,
aber wahrscheinlich, wenn da so eine
Schraube drüber ist, kann
vier Netzwerk-Ports.
Was ziemlich cool ist,
habe ich mir überlegt mit den vier Netzwerk-Ports,
weil ich werde darauf
wahrscheinlich
eins, zwei VMs laufen lassen
und die VMs kriegen einfach ihr eigenes
Netzwerk-Interface.
Da gehste einigen Problemen aus dem Bild.
Das glaube ich ganz praktisch. So, und dann hat man hier
neben,
hier neben hat man VGA,
HDMI,
USB, USB 3.
...
Moment, ich muss es
korrekt benennen.
USB 3.2
GAN 1
Das ist Display-Port?
Oh, tatsächlich,
das ist Display-Port.
Das wird schwierig anzuschließen. Ich muss erstmal
einen Display-Port zur HDMI-Adapter
gleich suchen. Das wird
PANES CHAMP.
Äh,
sag mal bitte die genaue Bezeichnung
für was?
Doch, doch, das ist Display-Port.
Du hast recht, das ist ein Display-Port.
Eindeutig, das ist ein Display-Port.
Ach so.
Nee, das ist ein...
Das ist ein Monitor. Guck mal, da ist oben ein Monitor drüber
abgebildet. Das ist Display-Port.
Das ist ein Display-Port. Ich muss gleich mal einen Display-Port
auf HDMI-Kabel suchen oder was in der Richtung, weil
das habe ich echt ein Problem, das gleich anzuschließen.
Da ist ein Monitor oben drüber. Guck, das ist Display-1.
Hier, das muss Display-Port sein.
Der Server,
das ist ein HP... Hier, nimm den QR-Code.
Scan den QR-Code.
Da müsste es eigentlich stehen.
Ähm,
das ist ein HP
Microserver Gen 10 Plus.
Die Variante mit dem
Xeon drinne. Viele Varianten gibt es davon nicht.
Also, das hier ist ein...
Kein Management-Port.
Den Management-Port...
Den Management-Port
kann man hier oben rein machen. Guck mal.
Hier oben ist... Man kann
ein ILO-Kit kaufen für 40 Euro
oder so, aber ich habe es jetzt erstmal gelassen.
Ich meine...
Das Ding steht 5 Meter hinter mir in einem kleinen
Ausstellkämmerchen. Da brauche ich, glaube ich, kein ILO.
So, ähm...
Dann haben wir hier USB
4 Stück
USB Gen 3
Äh, nein.
USB 3.2 Gen 1
Und hier vorne
haben wir nochmal
wie ihr hier seht
haben wir USB
Gen 3.2
2x1
1x2
Scheiß auf USB-Benahmung, Alter.
Ich hasse das USB-Form,
dass die sich so eine Scheiße ausgedacht haben.
Ne, also das hier vorne sind 10 Gigabit-Ports
und das hinten sind 5
Gigabit-Ports. Und angeblich
hat der Onboard noch ein USB 2
zum Booten, was ich ziemlich cool finde.
So, ähm...
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Ich zeige nochmal kurz die andere Hardware, die ich habe.
Also was ich mir gekauft habe hierfür
zeige ich mal. Also ich habe
noch ein paar Sachen, die ich schon eine Weile
hier rumliegen habe, die ich jetzt dafür
verwenden werde. Also was ich mir dafür gekauft habe
ist einmal die Kiste hier neu
und gebraucht von eBay, weil
ich mit den Dingern gute Erfahrungen gemacht habe
eine
eine weitere 10 Gigabit-Karte.
Das ist eine
ob das da steht, doch
hier Melanox
China-Chinesen-Hersteller
also Made
in China, ein Melanox
Connect X3
EM. Es ist
eine Low Profile, also Low Profile
taugliche 10 Gigabit-Karte.
Das ist das, was ich haben will. Low Profile
weil
da, guck da, Low Profile
Bracket.
So und das sollte
dann theoretisch da reinpassen.
Das gucken wir jetzt an. Wir machen das Ding jetzt auf und gucken rein.
Wie viel zieht da Strom?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das werden wir ausprobieren.
Da ist ja schon das Teil. Aber wir machen das jetzt
erstmal auf und bauen ein
und bauen die 10 Gigabit-Adapter ein.
Erstmal gucken, wie ich das aufkriege.
Chat, wie geht das auf?
Zeig mal her.
Ah ja.
Ich würde mal sagen, da dran
muss man drehen. Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt wird es natürlich toll.
Ich muss es so machen, dass ihr seht.
Das heißt, ich selbst kann nicht richtig
hingucken. Schauen wir mal.
So.
Ich mach das jetzt über die Kamera.
Weil ich selbst
nicht hingucken kann.
Mapp.
Danke schön für den Zap.
Huge Pork.
So.
Ah.
Ok.
Nice. Das ist einfach.
Ich mag das immer, wenn Gehäuse easy gehen.
Ohne, dass man sich irgendwie in die Finger
schneidet. Also,
was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Sieht sehr, sieht sehr kompakt aus.
Ich hoffe, wir können da irgendwie reingucken.
Das sieht sehr kompakt aus.
Wir haben 16 GB
RAM drin.
Ich habe noch einen zweiten
8 GB und einen zweiten
16 GB Liegel
rumfliegen von einer anderen Kiste.
Ich werde es aber jetzt erstmal so lassen,
im Auslieferungszustand, wie es ist.
Die kannst du auf
20 GB per Firmware
hochtacken.
Die, die,
die USB Ports?
Oder was?
Was ich dafür bezahle?
Ich glaube 700 Euro.
Brian, schick mal einen Link dazu,
wie man das hochtaktet.
Naja, zumindest haben wir hier einmal 16 GB
RAM drin.
Also, ich finde es preisleistungstechnisch durchaus in Ordnung.
So, da sieht man hier hinten den CPU.
CPU-Kühler drin.
Hier oben sind die Drive Base
für die Festplatten vermutlich mal stark.
Ach, guck mal, hier unten, da ist er.
Seht ihr? Hier. Da ist der interne
USB 2
Stecker.
So, wie kriegen wir das jetzt auf?
Also, hier hinten ist die Netzwelle. Wir müssen irgendwie an den
PCI-Express-Slot
und so,
guck hier, da ist PCI-Express, Leute.
Seht ihr? Da ist der PCI-Express-Slot.
An den kommen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall
nicht so einfach ran. Wir müssen das Ding irgendwie aufmachen.
So, gucken wir erst mal, wie man das vorne aufkriegt.
Ach, guck mal, da.
Logs.
Ach, hier, schaut mal, da.
Seht ihr das?
Da ist so was.
Okay.
Ich hab's entlockt.
Nee, ich hab's gelockt.
Es war entlockt.
Jetzt ist entlockt.
So, und auf der anderen
Seite ist auch entlockt.
Alles klar. Und kann ich jetzt
vorne abmachen dadurch,
oder wie?
Ah ja.
Aha.
Blende ab.
Blende ab. Ah, guck mal, da.
Wir haben
vier Laufwerks-
Slots.
Vier Laufwerks-Slots.
Ich hol mal kurz eine Festplatte zum
ausprobieren.
So.
So. Kommt der RGB rein?
Ja, muss für mehr FPS Boost.
So, mal gucken, wie das hier
funzt. Also, zeigt mal kurz her.
So.
Von der Idee her,
seht ihr da hinten die Anschlüsse?
Also sind zwei, sind zwei Stück
pro Seite.
Ob der Hotswap-fähig ist, weiß ich
nicht. Ich glaub, offiziell sagen sie
nein, es ist nicht Hotswap-fähig.
Einfach?
Ohne irgendwelche Laufwerks-Dinger
rein?
Nee, oder?
Braucht man da für
irgendwelche Laufwerks-
Rollen oder so?
Wie funzt das?
Die Schrauben vorne sind
wie- Ah, guck
dir mal da. Das hier ist für die Festplatten
die Schrauben. Das ist ja richtig
Big Brain. Guck mal da. Das ist
die Schrauben für die Festplatten, dass die besser
in die Schienen passen. Das ist
clever. Das find ich gut.
Schrauben wir- Dann schraube ich mir mal eine
dieser Schrauben oder vier Schrauben
mal raus.
Weil, naja.
Sonst krieg ich die Festplatte ja nicht rein, ne?
So, erste
Schraube.
Ich vermute
mal vier Stück pro Platte.
Falls ich da richtig liege.
Bei HP
sind da richtig schlaue Menschen unterwegs. Ja, ich
finde es gut, dass sie das so
ran gemacht haben und dass man nicht irgendein extra
Tütchen braucht, was man direkt
verliert. So.
Dann nehmen wir mal die Festplatte jetzt. Die habe ich da hinten
gemessen.
Von der Idee her heißt das also,
man nimmt die fest.
Wenn mir die jetzt runterfällt, die Platte ist übrigens
ripp wahrscheinlich. So, dann machen
wir jetzt einfach mal hier.
Tatsächlich,
guck mal da. Passt, easy.
Die muss man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so fest
anschrauben.
Ich brauch noch mal kurz den anderen.
Nee, der passt nicht, der ist zu klein.
So, machen wir erstmal hier die Schrauben dran.
Ich will die Festplatte wahrscheinlich eh nicht da drin haben.
Aber ich will mal die Laufwerks
Schächte ausprobieren.
So, andere Seite. Ich hoffe,
ihr seht, seht ihr was?
Ja, ne?
Ich müsste das eigentlich sehen.
Ja, ich sehe es auch in der Vorschau.
Man sieht halbwegs was.
Die Schrauben sind gut.
Die Schrauben verkanten sich nicht.
Oftmals verkanten sich
diese Billigschrauben bei Festpl...
Wie heißen diese? Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie diese Anschlüsse heißen.
Also die Standard Schrauben, die so in ziemlich jedem
Gehäuse drin sind, die verkanten
sich bei so billig China-Chinesen Schrauben immer ganz gerne.
So, jetzt haben wir die Festplatte
prepared. Jetzt
schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Komm rum.
So.
Und...
Plutsch.
Da ist er drin.
Hey, das ist easy.
Das ist easy. Und hier aufmachen und wieder rausziehen,
oder?
Aber wie kriegt man die
wieder raus?
So nicht?
Hab ich das jetzt
falsch gemacht?
Nee.
Guck mal.
Man muss fester drücken.
So geht's rein.
Jetzt kann man so machen. Guckt.
Dann geht's wieder raus. Das ist gut gemacht.
Find ich nice.
71 Watt TDP.
Das ist doch vollkommen egal, was der hat.
Wenn er brummt.
Wichtig ist, was der hat, wenn er
idle ist. So, Festplatte drin.
Die lasse ich wieder
raus.
Wobei, die lasse ich drin. Wir brauchen ja gleich was
zum Testen. Nee, ich mach die raus.
Ich heb... Ich dreh den Server jetzt dann auch ein bisschen
rum und wir gucken zusammen. So,
Festplatte am Start. Easy.
Die Karte hat aber nur SFP plus.
Ach, du meinst nicht USB
übertakten. Du meinst
die Netzwerkkarte übertakten. Nee, wozu?
Mein Switch kann ja plus 10
geben. Warum soll ich die übertakten?
Das verstehe ich.
Magst du deine Hose wieder? Wieso?
Hier, da.
Ahnfarbe.
Stellzmodus.
Ich will nicht, dass ihr
meine Hose seht.
GachiBuzz.
So, jetzt haben wir die Netzwerke. Wie kriegen wir die Netzwerkkarte
rein?
Also Festplatte habe ich jetzt gecheckt, wie das
funktioniert.
Die große Preisfrage ist,
wie kommen wir an
diesen, da, an
diesen PCI-Expressport?
Also, was wahrscheinlich schon
immer nicht funktioniert, ist
so.
Weil, ich muss ja hier
ah nee, ihr seht ja gar nichts.
Ähm, weil
ich muss ja hier an das Slotplech dran,
was da auf der Seite ist.
Hm.
Wie
geht das Ding
auf?
Also, wir müssen ja
da dran.
Da, an den Slot, da
müssen wir dran.
Manual lesen. Nee, das habe ich
weggeschmissen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Ich hab kein Manual.
Bevor wir was machen, rüsten wir erstmal die
Netzwerkkarte um zu Low Profile, würde ich
sagen. Und hoffen, dass es rein
passt.
Ah, Mist, zu groß.
Gut, dass ich immer zwei Stück
da hab.
Ah, eins.
Nächste Schraube.
Wisst ihr was?
Warum mache ich denn das auf der Kiste
obendrauf? Die Kiste kommt mal weg
und wir schrauben das hier um.
Klickt doch sonst keiner durch.
Man liest kein Manual richtig.
Also, wenn ich das Ding nicht aufkriege,
wird tatsächlich gegoogelt.
Ich google dann einfach
Open Microserver Gen10
Plus.
Da sind doch Bilder
für das System Board Removal. Tatsächlich.
Guck mal da.
Okay.
High IQ Chat.
Was sehe ich da?
Ich muss schrauben hinten.
Ich muss dann... Ah, hinten sind angeblich
sind da Schrauben?
Ach, guck mal da. Seht ihr?
Schrauben.
Das ist 16G
mit dem Xeon. Da sind Schrauben.
Die macht man auf und dann?
Und dann zieht man einfach dran.
Ich werde das überprüfen, ob das
funktioniert.
Ich hab noch ein zweites
16G RAM Modul und ein
5GB RAM Modul. Das werde ich wahrscheinlich
noch einbauen, aber nicht on stream.
Jetzt gucke ich mir das erstmal in Ruhe an.
So, also.
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Wie kam das jetzt hin? So, ne?
So?
Wie?
Chat, mache ich das richtig?
Ist das so richtig, ja?
So?
Oder muss das oben drauf?
Ne, das ist glaube ich schon richtig.
Ich meine, man sollte davon
ausgehen, weil ich mal
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
gelernt habe. Ich weiß, wie man das
Slotblech von einer Netzwerkkarte tauscht,
aber da täuscht euch immer nicht,
was ich da noch weiß. Ich mach das mal kurz
weg, sonst ist das zu unscharf.
Wer weiß denn
auch sowas noch?
Oh Mist!
Huh! Beinahe habe mir die Schraube runter
gefallen. Wie kriegt man das denn jetzt hier?
Ich glaube, der ist nicht magnetisch, den ich hier habe.
Okay. Und pass auf,
wir müssen High IQ machen. Der ist
magnetisch. Ist er nicht?
Okay.
Die Schrauben sind nicht
magnetisch, glaube ich, weil normalerweise
ist der magnetisch. Jaja.
Der ist magnetisch, aber die Schrauben
sind nicht magnetisch. Das sind Billy China
Chinesenschrauben, die sind nicht magnetisch. Okay.
Hallo Schrauben.
Vielleicht ist das
die High Performance Netzwerk
Kartenschraube. Die darf nicht
magnetisch sein, wegen Interferenzen
oder...
China-Logik. Was weiß ich.
So, guck mal.
Wo ist das Loch? Gachi-Buzz.
Ich sehe nichts,
das ist zu weit weg.
Boomer-Augen.
So.
Gut.
Netzwerk gerade umgebaut. Alles klar.
Jetzt
waren wir mal komplett weg.
Okay.
Kiste wieder her. Also, was soll ich
machen? Ich soll die Schrauben hinten
rausmachen.
Und dann dran ziehen, sagen
die Bilder zumindest. Also,
Schrauben rausmachen. Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt,
ob das stimmt, was da steht.
Okay. Schrauben raus.
Deswegen mag ich übrigens
diese Silikonmatte.
Man verliert deutlich weniger Schrauben.
Musst auf die Netzwerkkarte
als Userbericht schreiben,
die ferromagnetischen Eigenschaften der
mitgelieferten Schrauben lassen zu wünschen übrig.
Fivehead-Satz. Ja.
Das machen wir Amazon-Bewertung,
mache ich nachher.
Konnte nicht einbauen.
Katze hat Schraube verschluckt.
Eins von fünf.
Oder irgendwas.
Okay. Nice.
So. Und jetzt.
Und jetzt ziehen.
Guckt mal hier.
Guckt euch das mal an, wie gut das funktioniert.
Alter. Massive.
Sixkopf. Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hi-HQ-Konstruktion.
Das ist ja,
das ist wirklich, also.
Da reicht ein Fünferkopf nicht mehr.
Das muss schon ein Sechserkopf sein.
Das ist nice.
Das ist cool. Das mag ich.
So könnten alle ihre
Gehäuse aufbauen.
Stellt euch das mal vor. So ein normales
Desktopgehäuse mit einfach einem rausslidebaren
Mainboard-Schlitten.
Wäre das nicht nice?
Eigentlich braucht man das nicht. Aber trotzdem.
Aber das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Front-Server.
Hier muss ich nichts machen. Das ist ja fertig geworden.
Hier oben kann man übrigens
das ILO reinmachen, weil man sich ein ILO-Kit gekauft hat.
Ich habe kein ILO-Kit gekauft.
Und hier unten ist PCI-Express.
Das heißt, von der Idee her,
was muss ich jetzt machen? Ich muss
PCI-Express
die Schraube rausmachen.
Ich muss offenbar das Kit
herunter schmeißen.
PCI-Express
Schraube raus.
Schraube raus. Die Schrauben sind gut.
Also, das sind
Scheideschrauben. Nicht, dass es viel
kosten würde, aber es haben so viele Gehäuse
Schrottschrauben dabei. Unglaublich.
Was es gekostet hat?
Also, irgendwas um 700 Euro
in der Ausstattung.
Deswegen, ich habe übrigens auch hier einen mit
SSD genommen.
Nicht, weil ich das haben wollte mit SSD,
sondern weil, zahlt euch jetzt bei Amazon,
der mit SSD drinne
40 Euro günstiger
war, als der ohne SSD drinne.
Und ansonsten komplett
gleich.
Also, warum soll ich denn ohne SSD nehmen,
wenn das teurer ist? Amazon-Logik.
Leute,
ihr müsst mich ans Trinken erinnern, sonst tut mir
wieder der Hals weh später.
Für welchen Zweck wird der Rechner eingesetzt?
Stream Entertainment.
Nee, ich werde
Unraid drauf installieren. Ich bin ja
kein großer Unraid-Fan gewesen, die letzten
Jahre über.
Aber, ich habe mir das letztens angeguckt
und habe mir gedacht, ist eigentlich ein ganz
nicees System.
Mit relativ
wenig Magic im Hintergrund.
Wenn man sich das ein bisschen anguckt,
fand ich eigentlich gut.
Und dann dachte ich mir, bei der Gelegenheit
kann ich mir noch einfach mal ein bisschen
neue Hardware gönnen und das darauf
laufen lassen. Gibt es auch einen M2
Anschluss? Nein. Leider nicht.
Er hat einen internen USB,
aber es gibt leider keinen M2.
Deswegen, ich zeige euch gleich, was ich
sonst noch da habe. Müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ist das ähnlich wie Proximo? Eproximos kannst du
darauf auch betreiben, gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Proximox ist halt eine Virtualisierungslösung.
Und Unraid ist also hauptsächlich
eine Virtualisierungslösung.
Mit allen notwendigen Features dafür.
Unraid ist erstmal eine NAS mit
On-Top-Container und Virtualisierung.
Also, wenn man hauptsächlich
auf Virtualisierung steht
und irgendeinen Open Source
KVM Hypervisor haben will,
dann ist Proximox eine sinnvolle
Sache. Ansonsten einfach
ESX drauf und gut ist.
Open Media Vault?
Ja, Open Media Vault mochte ich
nicht wirklich.
Wo ist die SSD verbaut? Hier vorne
in den Laufwerkschächten.
Das was schon drinnen gesteckt hat.
So, wir probieren jetzt erstmal die
Netzwerk... Wo ist denn die Netzwerkkarte überhaupt?
Aha.
Okay.
Also, wie komme ich...
Leute, ich muss sagen, die Konstruktion...
Ich mag die Konstruktion, die ist simpel.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht besser
zeigen, weil das ein bisschen wackelig
ist. Aber guck mal, hier geht einfach
die Slotpläne, kommt in sie raus
und ich denke mal
ich kann jetzt einfach die Netzwerkkarte
nehmen
und hier einführen
in den Schlitz und dann
müsste das einfach
funktionieren.
Pork!
Fertig! Easy!
Ja, das ist ein gutes System.
Ich trage heute kein Holz
bei der Hemd, ich habe irgendwie so einen billigen...
Billiges...
Was ist denn das?
So ein Ärmelloses...
Ärmelloses drüberziehen
Ding, keine Ahnung.
So, und jetzt schrauben wir das einfach...
Also ich muss sagen, das System
gefällt mir echt gut.
Das ist mit ein paar Handgriffen gemacht.
Du reißt dir kein Bein aus, du schneidest dich
vor allem nicht, wie bei manchen billigen Sachen.
Du tust dir nicht weh,
wie bei manchen fetten Rechenzentrumskisten.
Nice! Also das gefällt mir wirklich
gut. Jetzt machen wir es rein
und guck mal, hier...
Tak! Klipps, klipps!
Und schon haben wir hier
unsere Netzwerkarte drin.
10G!
Easy as fuck!
Guck da!
10G am Start!
So einfach kann es sein.
Irgendwas um 700 Euro.
So!
Jetzt...
Ah, jetzt muss ich hinten erstmal zu...
Lasst mal kurz überlegen.
Leute, Leute...
Ich zeige euch mal kurz die andere Hardware, die ich dafür
zur Verfügung habe. Die habe ich jetzt nicht
extra dafür gekauft, die habe ich noch zum
größten Teil. Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob
wir da was einbauen bzw.
was wir davon verwenden. Ich zeige es euch
nur mal kurz.
Mal kurz hier weg.
Ahem...
Hartlich Ausschnitt, ja.
Also, was ich habe, ist...
Ich habe einmal einen Sandisk
USB-Stick. Den hat
mir der Chet empfohlen sogar. Chet hat
gesagt, gut, soll ich verwenden dafür.
Ich habe gedacht, Chet, ich glaube euch.
Wir wissen ja, der Chet ist
mittlerweile durch die ganzen Zaps so unglaublich
high IQ. Der kann eigentlich keinen Mist empfehlen.
USB-Stick. Und nur für den Fall
der Fälle, dass dieser USB-Stick
aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
weil ich habe gelesen, Unraid
funktioniert nur mit bis maximal 32
GB. Aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
weil ich meine, warum sollten aktuell...
Also, bescheuern.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Habe ich noch einen alten
60 GB USB-Stick ausgebuddelt.
So, das brauchen wir gleich zum System installieren.
Dann habe ich noch zu bieten
eine...
Die habe ich schon eine Weile.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen sollte.
Deswegen vielleicht ist das eine gute Sache hierfür.
Ich habe noch eine Zandisk.
Zandisk
Extreme Portable USB
SSD. Die
können wir als Cache verwenden dafür.
Weil, weil ich habe
mir überlegt, da ist zwar eine SSD
drinne, aber
die SSD ist ja nur per
SATA angebunden.
Und theoretisch ist
10 GB USB
schneller als SATA.
Kaufst du dir das ILO Kit noch nach?
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich habe
das ganze Zeug
ein Meter hinter mir.
Also, jetzt von hier
zwei Meter hinter mir
in so einem Miniserverraum stehen
und...
Ja...
Eigentlich brauchst du einen Strom und ich
brauch's nicht.
Das ist keine Festplatte, das ist eine SSD. Steht doch da.
Guck mal da. SR Portable
SSD.
Das ist keine
HDD.
Da ist eine
SSD drin.
Hier vorne ist eine SSD drin,
im Server. Das ist eine...
Ich kann's euch zeigen.
Zumindest habe ich das gekauft mit
SSD. Zumindest habe ich das gekauft
mit der SSD drin. Schauen wir mal, ob da wirklich eine
SSD drin ist.
Da, hier, guck mal.
Das da.
Oh.
Hab ich doch nicht gekauft mit der SSD.
Ist das... Ist das eine SSD
oder ist es eine Festplatte?
Das sieht nicht aus
wie eine SSD, ne?
Gerade hier oben
mit diesen Platten und so. Das sieht nicht aus
wie eine SSD.
Ja, gut.
Useless brauche ich nicht.
Also, mal davon abgesehen.
Ich habe die ja gar nicht wirklich beschlossen.
davon abgesehen ich habe die ja gar nicht wirklich bestellt
ich habe die version gekauft wo eine ich dachte ssd dabei ist die war aber 40
euro günstiger als die ohne also ist jetzt nicht als hätte ich da großartig
was verschenkt oder so was ist denn das ist das eine st 1000 dm 010 hdd bei
seagate technologies ok leute das ist doch keine ssd ich bekomme aber alles
klar ist aber auch egal die brauche ich nicht die kann ich die mache ich gleich
weg die werde ich nicht verwenden
das nicht eine smr platte ist smr das muss ich die muss ich die ringe
überlagern das glaube ich nicht oder dass bei einem ein terabyte smr ist
in terabyte ist so ein ding dass das machen die quasi morgens beim frühstücken
haben die das quasi schon
würde dir nicht empfehlen einen usb device in den cash oder das array zu
packen da sich die usb id bei jedem boot ändern kann zwar unwahrscheinlich wenn
immer die gleichen geräte angestellt sind aber nur alleine maus anschließen
kann schon nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das ist das ist blödsinn es mag
sich es mag sich die bus id was du meinst ändern das ist aber egal weil
linox linox ist ja nicht dumm was das angeht du hast ja hier def usb
nee es braucht usb ach misst def usb nee ach was ist es prokurs bf
bei all die usb bei all die wo ist es denn hier also du hast die du hast es
nicht nur nach bus all die sondern auch nach seriennummer und sowas die ändert
sich nicht bus bus
ach mist ich finde es nicht usb bei all die linox
zu bus ok das bus usb ich jetzt wo ist denn der mist
man konnte das ding doch entweder bei all die bei seriennummer bei sonst was
ach def disk ja das meine ich genau so das hast du bei all die das hast du bei
label bei partition bei pass oder bei uid und das ändert sich nicht und soweit
ich das letzte mal gesehen habe ist android relativ schlau und nimmt das auch
per also per all die die sich nicht ändert
also muss man sich denke ich keine gedanken machen so ok wo sind wir
stehen geblieben ich habe euch die ssd gezeigt ach ja und ich habe noch eine
andere option da darf der chat jetzt entscheiden was wir nehmen
wobei wir probieren einfach beides aus wir haben ja performance technisch können
wir das ja mal testen also ich mache das ding mal kurz weg also wir haben zur
auswahl einmal also das hier ist für system zum android installieren
eins davon immer dann haben wir als ssd cache das ding oder oder anstatt dem
hätte ich auch noch diese kombination hier zu bieten
das ist etwas neuer das habe ich mir noch vor nicht allzu langer zeit mal
zugelegt ich habe eine 2 terabyte 790 evo und ich
habe noch ein m2 zu usb enclosure
jetzt ist die frage chat was nehmen wir davon wir nehmen ganz ehrlich wir nehmen
beides ich probiere beides aus also rein von von der zuverlässigkeit der
durfte das hier in der ecke besser sein max hat zum ende des monats kein geld
mehr klar ich gebe nie was aus ich gebe ich gebe so gut wie nie was aus und wenn
ich was ausgebe dann ab und zu mal für ein bisschen technik scheiß ich habe ich
habe wirklich keinerlei probleme was das angeht der einzige grund warum ich immer
mal wieder meinen chef nerven wegen mehr geld ist nicht so sehr weil ich mir
denke mist ich komme nicht über die runden sondern weil ich nicht will dass
das so billig wird für den arbeitgeber weil ich sehe was es umliegen teilweise
für kohle gibt für stellen die das machen was ich mache oder das machen was
kollegen von mir machen und ich sehe es nicht ein dass sie bei uns irgendwie mit
nur zwei drittel des gehalt wegkommen das kann ja nicht sein das für alle
schlecht weil wir haben definitiv leute da weiß ich die brauchen das geld und
das schöne ist wenn einer mehr bekommt kommen alle mehr
zumindest stimmt so nicht das stimmt nicht aber es ist dann potenziell
einfacher ok du fährst doch einen dicken porsche nein jetzt genau was ich für
autofahrt schätzt das ist weit entfernt von irgendwas sportlichem es ist sehr
agil soll das war es leute also das ist das ist die
hardware ich bin nur grad am überlegen kann man vielleicht vielleicht
kann man irgendwas davon innen rein machen
da müssen wir mal schauen kam also hier ist übrigens hier ist
übrigens der usb stick von dem wir buten ich leg das mal kurz weg
und ich schraube leute ich schraube ich schraube erst mal hinten wieder zu
weil ich kenn mich ich kenn mich ich heb das ding gleich hoch und mir rutscht
hinten das ding raus fällt auf die er ist kaputt
deswegen schraube ich moment falsch rum da muss ich zuschrauben
der chat wird im chat würde das natürlich gefallen
der würde dann so was schreiben wie das know he lacks critical information oder
irgendwie sowas kurz ich kann sie mir richtig vorstellen ich weiß genau wie
das im chat lauf ich würde das ding hochheben ja ich würde das ding so
hochheben und die leute im chat würden sehen gleich fällt dem max das ding
raus und der chat würde dann nicht sagen max achtung gleich folgt das ding
raus sondern die würden machen people laugh he lacks critical information und
würden warten bis das ding mir runter fällt soll der da ins server ablösen ja
vielleicht vielleicht das noch das ist so also habe ich das erwartet ja nur mit
dem unterschied dass es jetzt schwachsinn ist was ihr schreibt weil er
note er note he knows he doesn't lack critical information
das ist richtige loch
he
ein die schraube ist weg ich habe sie noch gefangen bär
warum geht es nicht richtig rein was ist das hier was ist das warum geht das net
zack muss man genauer hingucken
er note ja er note
ich habe in die falsche richtung gedreht profis am werk
um das überlasse ich deiner fantasie so alles drin alles dran mein opa hätte
jetzt gesagt oder besser gesagt meine oma hätte gesagt sitzt bast wackelt
und hat luft nur dass es keine luft hat
die legs critical information ich lecke keine critical information mehr
heute ich kriege kopfwehe von der impfung heute und mir tut der arme die
antenne ist bald da so jetzt ist die frage also ich muss auf jeden fall
die ssd irgendwo hier vorne an den usbs anschließen weil die usbs hier vorne
sind 10 gigabit die sache ist jetzt nur die kann ich das nicht irgendwie hier
reinlegen moment ich pack das mal kurz aus wir packen wir packen den gra mal
kurz aus hier wie geht das ich mag so dinger nicht die schlecht aufgehen
muss alles ohne großen kraftaufwand öffnen bar sein so also haben wir einmal
eine sandisk ziemlich kleines teil und wir haben den usb kam was das für ein
hässliches usb kam was nö hydra haben wir das emote dafür
ach so das ist ein adapter jetzt erkenne ich das das ist irgendwie ok naja das ist
ok das ist dumm da muss ich anderes kabel nehmen ich habe ich hab noch eins ich
habe hier irgendwo nen usb c auf a ist das oder chat ist das typa also das ist
das ist definitiv usb c und das hier das hier ist typa glaube ich ne übrigens
wir machen kein wir machen gerade kein dark kreisel klein also heute stimmt
nicht aber wir machen vielleicht vielleicht machen wir heute abend da
auch grausel klein das hat ja vielen gefallen was mir gefallen hat also
können wir ich schmeiß mal kurz den kram hier in die ecke kann man nicht
einfach wartet mal ich habe eine idee können wir nicht also gehen wir mal von
aus wir stecken das da vorne rein so gehen wir mal von aus wir stecken das da
vorne rein so
hallo usb common wir stellen das da ne hier rein kann ich da nicht liegen da ist
er der deckel da ist er der deckel davor das funktioniert ja nicht
ne das das klappt nicht ich muss das irgendwie vorne neben dran legen
vielleicht war ein bisschen velcro dran oder so ein pappens an die seite oder
mal schauen gut das war mal nachher also das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter
mit beschäftigen ist das hier hin schauen wir noch schnell mal in den
anderen krempel rein habe ich denn das hier gut das muss ich nicht aufmachen
das ist eine m2 aber das ding das ding gucken wir uns mal an das ist ja so ein
so ein wechsel also nie war es kein wechsel haben das hier so ein usb zu m2
also ich werde beides mal anschließen weil mich einfach die performance
unterschiede auch interessieren würden ich muss den scheiß nur mal kurz
all das ist kacke verpackt man mal öffnen und den server mal runter stellen
weil sonst sieht man nix so welcher ist echt praktisch ja ich habe mir auch mal
so zwei säckchen gekauft mit diesen velcro aufklebern die schon so zurecht
geschnitten sind die sind äußerst praktisch so machen das teil mal auf
ich pfeffer das alles auf die erde oder was der fuck was ist denn hier alles
drinne thank you
vor drei wo linken ist icy box weg alles alles in die ecke pfeffern
gratis pass was haben wir hier drin ach guck mal hier hätten wir hier hätten wir
zur abwechslung gut dass ich das gekauft habe wenn überhaupt kann man zumindest
das usb kabel hierfür verwenden
so wie funzt das jetzt moment chat chat das muss man kurz angucken wie funzt das
jetzt da sind schrauben das ist der usb kommt das muss man das aufschrauben und
die m2 wahrscheinlich kommt die m2 dann da rein das testen wir jetzt mal hat
jetzt zwar nicht so direkt was mit der servo kiste zu tun aber mein warum nicht
warum ich probieren jetzt mal aus riesen warum ist es eigentlich so eine mega
fette verpackung für so was kleines checkt es jemand warum muss das so groß
sein warum muss man da so viel direkt fabrizieren für eine mini m2 platine ich
funz chat was meint ihr wo muss man aufmachen auf der seite oder auf der
seite ich habe das handbuch schon weggeschmissen ich lecke critical
information welche seite ist die richtige wahrscheinlich beide weil es
sonst nicht slide ist boah ist das ein räudiger schraubenzieher
boas das das ist müll das fühlt sich echt an wie so ein 5 cent china chinesen
ding ist es wahrscheinlich auch das fühlt sie nicht nur so an schaffst du
nicht mit einer hand drauf zu lassen ok man muss beides ab machen sonst was
das ripp bei den nicht ripp ok das macht billigen eindruck leute das macht
billigen eindruck das ding guck mal ich krieg es noch nicht mal mehr drauf da
wo der usb what the fuck doch so so
machen wir mal auf
der ist von chinesischen für chinesische kinderhände der schraub
zieher ist es wirkt echt so also du kannst damit eigentlich nichts machen
boah ok das ist das ist richtiger pains champ von der handhabung alles klar ok
und jetzt rein damit gatschi bass ok leute mir fehlt eine schraube ist die
schraube vielleicht bei der ssd in der packung drin gewesen die packung die ich
gerade quer durch den raum geschmissen hat könnte könnte das möglich sein
ssd only array mache ich nicht die ssd ist nur als cash die schraube ist beim
mainboard dabei ja gut das mainboard ist in dem falle das ding ok dann muss ich
mal kurz graben ich hab das mehr durch den raum gepfeffert das liegt in
da ist es skruz was auch immer mir diese teile das ist wenn ich was verloren
habe oder so nice die dinger kann man ja nicht falsch rein stecken also die
gibts ja gehen ja nur in eine richtung was hey max so oft wie du den was
kak wait hat nehmen einfach eine schraube und fallen sie ein bisschen ab
ach cash natürlich nämlich in cash das ist zu high IQ für mich der witz das
kapier ich nicht ich krieg mit diesem ding ich raste ich trinke gleich durch
ohne scheiß trinke gleich durch bis ich das da drinnen hat man monka es wer hat
sich dieses system ausgedacht alter
what the fuck so ok install wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen man braucht doch
dieses dumme gehäuse gar nicht zum testen ich meine wozu brauche ich das
gehäuse wenn ich einfach so einstecken kann also kühlung ach was kühlung lull
keine kühlung bei mir hat das ding auf mainboard wenn es in m2 slot pappt auch
keine kühlung wozu kühlung das ding steckt so normalerweise ohne jegliche
kühlung aufs mainboard warum sollte das kühlung brauchen und im windzug auf
mehmer ok da ist da ja da lass ich das lass ich mir gefallen ok chat ihr habt
mich überzeugt ich sollte das besser in das gehäuse stecken ja ok ok ok
verstehe wo ist denn jetzt vorne und wo es hinten gewesen so glaube ich war das
ne reingesteckt
oh nee please diese mini schrauben alter ok wartet mal 3 ach du scheiße wartet mal
drei stunden dann habe ich das wieder drinnen aber ihr seht ihr das was ist
das für eine schraube man
ich lege kürtigen informatisch und wisst ihr was das ding ist nicht mal
magnetisch hier ach du große ok ok ganz ruhig einfach
oh gott komm an bruh oh nee oh nee oh nee
ok erster erster erster ist drin nächst
jetzt mal ganz im ernst warum machen die da nicht normale schrauben hin jetzt
ach nicht es passt nicht da drin ist zu 90 prozent luft
ok ok wir machen progres wir machen fortschritt kosten minimieren weil
china chinesen kram ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
so guck mal guck mal gleich haben wir noch zwei schrauben dann geht's dann
geht's los erste schraube dann schalten wir nämlich die
kiste an und hauen andere drauf also vorher schrauben wir die kiste zu und
hauen dann andere drauf nach test dann gucken wir uns auch gleich noch mal hier
den stromverbrauch an ok nice nice nice gut finished
lasst es mal hier liegen ja kommt alles hier mal auf den schreibtisch
alles klar hier haben wir die usb sticks dann schrauben wir jetzt mal zu dann
schrauben wir jetzt mal zu lasst mal überlegen habe ich irgendwas vergessen
chat ich möchte jetzt nicht critical information lecken habe ich irgendwas
vergessen was ich machen muss so lange es noch auf ist festplatten rein ja
festplatten rein muss ich machen aber festplatten rein habe ich ja schon
ich will es ja nur testen im endeffekt also am ende kommt die kommen dann
irgendwie 18 t platten oder so mal gucken oder oder eine 18 t parity und
irgendwie keine ahnung mal schauen ich mache es erst mal ohne an leute ich lasse
es offen ich lasse es offen ich mache ohne an weil ich den stromverbrauch
sehen will ich will den stromverbrauch sehen ohne platte ohne ssd ohne alles
aber mit usb stick gebootet weil oftmals wenn die dinger im bios sind
beziehungsweise selbst erst machen brauchen die mehr strom als wenn die
ins betriebssystem gebootet sind deswegen machen wir uns mal einen
unrate usb stick würde ich sagen das wenn er offen ist ist nicht schlimm
wir machen uns einen unrate usb stick gibt es diesen unrate unrate download
gibt es diesen unrate usb key ersteller auch für linux wieso steckst du nicht
die mx 500 rein weil es sata ist und sata ist langsamer als 10 gigabit ssd
als 10 gigabit usb also die usb ssd ist wahrscheinlich schneller
ok den usb creator gibt es noch für windows download unrate
kannst die iso ich würde die iso flaschen aber es gibt kein iso unrate ist
das einzige was irgendwie der meinung ist iso was das ist zu advanced iso gibt es
nicht ok also wir nehmen jetzt den hier moment muss ich den die musik dazu die
passt ja wieder gut doch es gibt kein iso kein offizielles iso wir nehmen
erstmal den sandisk muss man aufmachen intrusion detektion meint ihr meint er
detektiert ob das offen ist und wenn es offen ist plasen die lüfter mehr oder
was das könnte tatsächlich sein ja wir hatten diese usb sticks wieder
verpackt geht wieder nett auf die musik im beis schon der wahnsinn so da ist
er usb stick am start also usb creator oh misst welches kabel kann ich denn jetzt
überhaupt rausziehen um hier usb zu createn ich glaube das hier ist für die
elgato karte die brauchen wir nicht jawoll hab übrigens guckt mal dieser
usb stick ist richtig feifett guckt mal passt mal auf ich dachte erst als ich
die packung aufgemacht habe pack das ist ein usb c usb stick aber jetzt passt
mal auf es ist dual wield und hier ist der usb 3 1 ich will nicht den
höchstmöglichen stromverbrauch möchte den eidl stromverbrauch messen ist er
nicht zu groß da steht was von 32 g ernsthaft das ist wirklich so das habe
ich im vorfeld schon gelesen im forum
so nach dem öffnen also dein usb stick muss über eine
gültige gut verfügen macht er wahrscheinlich mindestens ein höchstens
32 g was ihr wollt mir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen dass das ding nicht
funktioniert mit dem größeren usb glaube ich nicht warum das ergibt keinen
sinn warum sollte das so sein
meint hat er das jetzt in die leine connect to host usb drive sandisk memory
zone install ja ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt sandisk ok also wenn das jetzt
wirklich nicht funktioniert da muss ich echt muss ich echt eine runde keck keck
w der erkennt den wirklich nicht wie schlecht kann man eigentlich sein
immer dass man immer extra wurst machen muss weil die hersteller irgendeinen
kack machen der komplett weltfremd ist hatte wir proxmox mit full disk
encryption laufen ne aber wir haben schon mal full disk encryption von hand
gemacht mit zum ssh entlocken also andreid usb stick larger 32 gb larger
das size matter gachibas no in 60 g andreid image ist 450 mb ja warum
warum gehen wir das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn warum sollte der
maximal 32 gigabyte erlauben hast du dein usb stick eine gültige gut bestimmt
warum soll er das nicht haben
ernsthaft ich ich meine ich habe hier ja noch den wo habe ich ihn denn hier ich
habe noch diesen ganz alten usb 2 16 g aber den wollte ich dafür jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht verwenden die beschränkung kommt nur vom andreid tool nehmen ein
anderes und fertig ja anderes was
achter brauchen in 32 je fad 32 ja das können wir dem können wir abhilfe schaffen
dem können wir abhilfe schaffen das kein problem je partet
dem können wir abhilfe schaffen der guck mal der hat 32 100 114 also scheint
irgendwie auch mehr zu gehen ja aber dem können wir dem können wir
echt abhilfe schaffen ist kein problem muss bloß aufpassen das ist meine
linux fest bleibt dass der usb stick delete new fad 32 ja keine ahnung
perfekt so wollte ich das schon immer mal haben save aber ich lese mal durch ob
es noch ein paar andere sachen gibt fest usb usb kompatible 64g ne geht nicht
wei wei ich hasse solche antworten ich hasse solche antworten der typ fragt wird
das funktionieren wei wei storage weil in facking 64 g stick 1 cent mehr kostet
als in 32 g stick und im zweifelsfall wegen real leveling sogar noch länger
hält was eine bescheuerte antwort ich hasse solche das ist wie das
microcontroller forum der muss es doch nicht möglich okay okay wir machen was
an rate create usb manuel man manueli manueli manueli aha legacy guckt mal
da legacy preparing usb legacy aha okay es gibt keine iso
manuel install method aha aha okay plug usb device into bla bla bla
set volume label to unrate all uppercase man soll das zipp runterladen
content extracting also im prinzip soll man das zipp auf den usb stick
extracten und wenn man uefi boot machen will was wir beide machen wollen soll
man das directory umbenennen von efe minus zu efe und dann make bootable
script ausführen okay
okay note this method only works for devices 32 gigabyte and small das macht
keinen sinn das liegt bestimmt nur an der
partition die maximal 32 gigabyte sein darf das machen wir jetzt trotzdem dass
das funktioniert schon so ich muss es mal kurz verkleinern hier
um sehe ich nix also was soll ich runterladen das zipp das da ok gib ihm
save so und jetzt go to the download space ok also ich soll das ding dann kann
ich das gleich schon mal rückgängig machen was ich hier gemacht habe das
stimmt nämlich nicht ich soll eine neue fad 32 partition anlegen die unrate
heißt so das ganze ist was weiß ich 21 gigabyte groß perfekt genauso groß
muss es sein
so haben wir ein usb stick angelegt mit dem label unrate or quit mehr müssen
wir nicht nicht machen und jetzt muss ich einfach das zipp
extracten oder glaube das war es sudo minus i mount def sdb 1 nach mnt
so kopieren wir jetzt mal nach von home max downloads unrate das ding dahin und
sagen unzip unrate unrate server fertig easy so unrate löschen wir wieder das
zipp fertig wenn das alles ist auch bei niederkommens you have a rename efi
zu efi anders efi minus zu efi ok mv efi minus efi minus zu efi efi ok passt
und jetzt run make bootable script
unmount usb das muss ich runter kopieren oder was also quasi mnt make bootable
linux ok das in das kripp gucke ich mal rein bevor ich bevor ich das ausführe
zur unmount mnt stopp warum
warum das kripp vom stick ausführen ich kann das kripp nicht vom stick ausführen
weil die sagen ich soll es unmount ne ne ne ne die meinen man soll das
runter kopieren vom usb stick weil danach muss ich in usb stick unmount so wir
gucken wir gucken mal kurz was das kripp macht so nichts
ach guck mal der guckt einfach ob unrate als label gesetzt ist deswegen muss man
beim partition beim v32 musste man als label unrate setzen das ist dass er den
usb stick findet und was macht er danach mountet sich das ganze noch mal und dann
kopiert er irgendwelche dinger um ok sieht nicht sieht nicht gefährlich aus
können wir ausführen was wie soll ich es ausführen mit bash warum
warum egal mich hinterfragt das nicht so make bootable
the following device appears to be the unrate usb flash drive permit uefi boot
und yes ok unrate os flash drive is now bootable and may be ejected ok alles klar disconnect
wie sieht das ding jetzt unter windows aus wenn man sich es anguckt ja da ist
der ganze miss drauf
probier mal aus probier mal aus warum nicht ok usb stick
elgato rein ok oh das ist ganz schön warum ist
der usb stick warm geworden ich meine sollte doch nicht der usb stick
soll doch nicht wirklich warm werden von ich kopiere mal kurz ein paar mb drauf
was ist das
max lies chat da steht er hat m copy not found
was ist m copy stand das eben dass er irgendwas nicht gefunden oh m copy command
not found info ins also hier nach hier nach
moment da muss man kurz gucken was habe ich schon nie gehört
wo kommt das überhaupt her wo kommt er diese meldung überhaupt her aus dem
zweiten script ach hier cp sus linux tmp unrate und
was ist dollar source source mount crep ah vom usb stick ach scheiß drauf das
wetschauf funktionieren wenn ich wenn ich machen wir das einfach neu und dann
machen wir es mit dem 16 g und dem offiziellen wenn das nicht geht ok dann
stecken wir den usb stick doch mal rein guckt mal hier ist ein usb 2 interner
usb 2 stecker zum booten ich finde das ist eine wirklich gut
durchdachte angelegenheit hier mit dem internen usb 2 das gefällt mir das hat
was ich habe den alten 16 g stick ja aber den will ich eigentlich nicht
verwenden der ist irgendwie kann und 12 jahre alt oder so ok gut alles klar so
dann schließen wir mal an hdmi kabel kommen hier hdmi wie die coolen leute
sagen was ist das für eine kiste das ist ein hp microserver gen 10 plus wie
sie im titel steht
oh shit das war ja ein display port leute ich habe es ganz vergessen das war
ein display port
wie kriege ich ich kann kein vga nehmen weil ich will euch das ja zeigen mit
der capture karten die capture karten nur ich habe irgendwo einen hdmi auf
display port wartet mal kurz
aber das finde ich doch jetzt hier hängt was hinter meinem schreibtisch
da ist ein display port dran auf der reichte der andere seite ja ein
usb
Warum machen die da eigentlich ein Display-Port dran?
Wo geht denn das Kabel hin?
Was für ein Kacke, man! Warum ist da kein HDMI-Port?
Warum machen die da eigentlich ein Display-Port?
Ist das Problem?
Das HDMI-Kabel kaputt?
ich richtig dran ich hatte selbst ich hatte das zeug am output richtig hängen geblieben
ok game capture wow der bläst gerade volle pulle jetzt ist er leiser geworden
ich glaube der hat gebootet ich glaube der hat gebootet ich komme mal kurz in meinen router
aber ich würde ja schon gerne was sehen ip server dhcp leases
keine ahnung da hätte ich jetzt mal drauf gucken müssen es müsste 2
ich weiß nicht was der für ein ip jetzt bekommen hat als er gebootet hat
warum geht diese kakt ist warum ist das immer so eine rotz warum habe ich diesen kacke überhaupt
wenn es nie funktioniert nee dynamic hab ich nee er hat nicht gebootet er hat nicht gebootet doch
da hat gebootet moment was ist das hier ach nee das ist mein desktop nee da hat mich gut ok
du hast eine ip kvm ja irgendwo keine ahnung die mac vom server habe ich nicht aber ich sehe
das ja anhand des haus namens welche das ist und welches netz das ist dass es nicht gezogen hat
habe ich vielleicht das elgato zeug hier drin irgendwie eingerichtet so dass es nicht funktioniert
er hat kein management interface so also vielleicht ist das hdmi kabel kaputt möglich möglich
ach so leute ich habe gar kein netzwerkabel drinnen fällt mir ein
da kann sich gar keine ip ziehen aber ich will auch gar nicht dass er sich eine ip
zieht ich will dass ich den output sehe von dem teil ok leute wir schalten noch mal aus
übrigens jetzt sind wir eidel bei 20 watt was durchaus ok aussieht ich schalte noch
mal aus ich schalte noch mal komplett aus vielleicht ist das vielleicht ist das hdmi
kabel kaputt ich hatte ich hatte mit diesem kabel in verbindung mit der elgato schon mal
probleme aber ich finde auf die schnelle glaube ich jetzt kein anderes hdmi kabel
so er ist aus er ist aus ok er ist aus noch mal an aber ich wollte nur sp stick rausziehen
vorher das soll ja gar nicht richtig hast du bei twitter mitbekommen nft scams bei monats
monte gewinnspiel ach keine ahnung was mit dem kerl los ist er ich verstehe ich verstehe
ganz ehrlich ich checks ja eh gar nicht was alle warum alle so auf nfts abgehen ist mir
komplett schleierhaft manche display ports unterstützen nur ausgabe auf display ports
das wäre ziemlich hängen geblieben wenn bei einem display port auf hdmi adapter kein
hdmi unterstützt werden werden würde oder leute ich brauche ein anderes hdmi kabel ich
muss mal kurz suchen ich habe ich habe so viele ich weiß nur mit bock
aha das sieht ein bisschen erhaben aus
was ist nur ein koden amazon baiting ach scheiße guckt mal guckt mal das ist ein
ist ja noch schlechter das ist ein ich weiß gar nicht was ist denn das überhaupt was was
ist das hier chat chat sagt mir was das ist was ist das was ist das überhaupt hdmi mini
hdmi oder sowas kack warum habe ich so was überhaupt wer braucht denn sowas useless
der ding das habe ich glaube für den raspberry pi mal gehabt das kann schon sein ich brauche
den hdmi kabel leute ich brauche hdmi kabel ich brauche hdmi kabel usb verlängerung habe
ich in amazon basic was was
jetzt aber blöde frage für wie wir für wie wahrscheinlich haltet ist das hdmi kabel
wirklich das problem ist 100 prozent quatsch das hdmi kabel ist bestimmt was anderes egal
ich suche mal weiter
ich habe eins ich habe eins amazon basic glaube ich amazon basic aber mir egal ob das funktioniert
amazon basic funzt in der regel die sind die sind so basiert based hdmi kabel ok tauschen
wir aus und gucken dann ob es funktioniert hdmi müsst es eigentlich durch schleifen
und an einem monitor gucken ob es funktioniert macht die elgato nicht normalerweise ich stöpsel
die leute ich stöpsel die nochmal ab die macht nämlich normalerweise so komische lichter
one moment please
ok jetzt schalte ich wieder ein
active dongle must be used or passive dongle will not allow video to be displayed
jetzt ernsthaft mann ich will den monitor da dran anschließen
das kann doch nicht in den ernst sein oder das kann doch nicht in den ernst sein dass
ich eben spezial ok ist das ding aktiv wahrscheinlich nicht sonst wird sich funktionieren
das ist ein hdmi man weiß es nicht das ist bestimmt ein passives kabel ja guck mal ok
wie ich hab keine ahnung wie ich da ich hab ich hab kein vga anschluss wozu eigentlich
für das eine mal wurde uns kurz das bios zeigen ich will ins bios gucken ich will zum
beispiel im bios virtualisierungskram einschalten und so was ich muss ich muss doch ins bios
kommen von meiner kiste soll jetzt kein ist doch jetzt keine option nicht nicht ins bios
zu kommen weil ich mich nicht anstöpseln kann ich habe kein ich habe noch kein vga kabel
mehr wo soll ich den vga kabel haben vga kabel braucht man das hat nein das hat theoretisch
die option auf dem management port aber ich habe kein management port ich habe tatsächlich
ein ip kvm irgendwo leute irgendwo habe ich ein ip kvm aber wirklich irgendwo mit vga
ich weiß nicht wo der ist wirklich nicht ich ich lecke critical cables ja ich sehe es
also ohne scheiß das ip kvm ding habe ich seit zwei jahren nicht mehr gesehen oder so
keine ahnung wo das ist wirklich absolut kein schimmer wie komme ich da jetzt ran
habe ich irgendwo oga nee ich habe kein vga mehr gehe auch bestimmt nicht zu meinem nachbar
und frage hast du ein paar vga kabel weil ich auch was habe um das anschließen zu müssen
also ok was gehen würde ist ich schließe einfach mein display an dann seht ihr es nicht
das würde aber das das will ich jetzt nicht on stream machen da kann ich weil wenn ich
wenn ihr nix seht ist langweilig also wenn schon müsst ihr das sehen oder ich kann es
sein lassen auf bildschirm richten ich überlege gerade wo ist das wo ist das ip kvm ich schaue
mal kurz in meine kiste ob ich es zufälligerweise finde auf den ersten blick
ja
Ich habe meine Playstation Vita gefunden.